so you think he can dance he's back on
the road
[Applause]
[Music]
yes episode 3 of the falcon and the
winter soldier is here and with it a ton
of new easter eggs
delicious snacks and theories including
who i think the power broker is but
before we begin hulk smash that like and
subscribe button
because here we go well if it isn't a
wholesome grc ad showing all the good
they're doing in the world helping
displace people from the blip
get the aid they sorely need but as
we'll find out the grc
isn't all it's cracked up to be carly
and the flag smashers raid at grc supply
depot in lithuania where they find the
grc has stockpiled over six months of
supplies while the refugees suffer
last episode we learned that the new
captain america works with grc to
maintain stability across the globe
so there's something bigger going on
here hinting that the grc
may have more nefarious plans in germany
cap and lamar have tracked down the last
safe house carly and her team visited
remember chicken liver guy well he's
interrogated by
cap who loses his cool when the german
spits in his face
do you know who i am i'm batman and can
you imagine the real captain america
exploding like that
the writers are slowly setting up ways
this cap is fundamentally different than
steve
rogers this will make it more justified
when bucky and falcon eventually take
back the shield this new cap thinks that
carly is getting help from an unknown
source so we'll keep a pin in that for
now
and we also learned that cap is in touch
with langley suggesting he's working
hand in hand with the cia
but in order to track down new leads
they're going to need someone with a
better
hand a little joke at bucky's vibranium
arm
bucky says he wants to meet with zemo
one on one after all they have a history
together it's somewhat ironic that zemo
broke the winter soldier out and now
it's the other way around and hands up
if you totally got hannibal lecter vibes
here
zemo greets bucky by reciting some of
the code words once used to control him
bucky wants to know if hydra has
something to do with this new super
soldier serum and
just like hannibal lecter zemo is able
to figure out what his visitor wants
you'll notice zemo reading a book by
famous philosopher niccolo machiavelli
titled
fortune is a raging river in which
machiavelli argues that fortune is the
decider of
half of our actions but the other half
we have the ability to influence
bucky is able to break zemo out and who
knew it was as easy as starting a fight
and wearing an officer's uniform
of course falcon isn't too pleased when
he sees a zemo strolling into their
hideout but bucky wants falcon to trust
him on this just like falcon trusted
steve rogers when he refused to sign the
sokovia accords
so zemo is loaded after all he is
royalty
check out these vintage cars which
include a packard and ford greyhound
these things can sell for hundreds of
thousands of dollars
in the trunk of one he has a collection
of knives guns and what appears to be a
grenade or rocket launcher because
no classic car is complete without one
it's here we also see zemo find his
iconic
jacket and purple mask amass will see
him wear later on in the episode
there's even a theory out there that the
reason it's purple with those
vertical lines is to mock the avengers
purple being the color of thanos who
successfully achieved his plans against
the avengers in infinity war
zemo knows how to ride in style in his
private jet and his own alfred s
butler oznik a name in slovak which
translates to
butcher zemo really do be live in that
villain batman life we once again get a
look at bucky's book filled with the
names of those he's supposed to make
amends with although in this episode we
see a few more names than were revealed
in episode 1.
the only two names of note here are
nakajima the old japanese man whose son
died by bucky
and atwood a former u.s senator and
member of hydra who we saw in episode
one
zemo is reading another book here
psychotherapist peter schellenbaum's das
nine in delibera my german is terrible
or its english version how to say no to
someone you
love in which he argues that if partners
do not learn to say no in a relationship
they will soon forget how to say
yes which soon creates an inability to
communicate with one another the notepad
was apparently steve rogers when he came
out of ice the same one he used to write
down things to experience that he missed
while he was gone
things like marvin gaye's troubleman and
it just so happens the day this episode
was released
is also marvin gaye's birthday zemo
talks about heroes who become
symbols for getting their flaws this is
a jab at the avengers and especially the
new captain america
he even uses the line then city's fly
referring to sokovia
literally levitating in age of ultron
they are on their way to madrapore a
fictitious city in southeast asia
founded by
pirates which is split between the
wealthy high town and crime ridden
lowtown
sam even makes reference to it like
skull island kong's fictitious home
island and if you haven't seen my
godzilla vs kong videos you should
totally do that
shameless self-plug in a grc camp in
latvia carly says goodbye to a dying
woman who we'll come to know as donya
modani she was the woman who took carly
and
others after being displaced in
madrapore when the blip occurred she
says she's sorry to danya and we're not
sure if that's because she
couldn't do anything to help her or for
what she's about to do
carly will later blow up a grc supply
depot with
people inside it something that really
catches dovitch off guard
she didn't have to kill those people but
she did because she says quote
it's the only language they understand
zemo leads sam and bucky to the brass
monkey a bar in lowtown where they hope
to find selby a woman who might be able
to lead them to the power broker we even
see a power broker is watching you
graffiti here in the background in order
to pull this off
bucky has to disguise himself as the
winter soldier under zemo's command
and falcon a criminal known as conrad
mack after some delicious snake entered
shots things don't go well for the team
as they're attacked by some thugs before
making enough noise to get the attention
of selby now there are a bunch of people
taking videos of this altercation with
their phones
i wouldn't be surprised if news of the
winter soldier coming back made
headlines after this putting falcon and
bucky on the run
with the new captain america set to hunt
them down
through the back rooms containing cash
and drugs the team meets up with selby
who tells them the serum is here in
madrapore with a man named dr wilford
nagle the last name nagel happens to be
one of a famous philosopher
thomas nagel whose work focused on
ethics and altruism amongst other things
their plan however goes to hell when
falcon receives a call from his sister
sarah
and come on falcon you're really gonna
leave your phone on during an undercover
mission
selby is killed by an unknown assailant
however it's fair to assume it's sharon
carter who did it since we see her
briefly in the bar moments earlier now
it looks like selby's death will be
pinned on zemo bucky and falcon so they
have to bounce all the while evading
asea bounty hunters promised
000 bitcoin for their deaths 1 000
bitcoin is roughly 60 million dollars
and
surprise surprise they're saved by
sharon carter the great niece of agent
peggy carter
founder and director of shield now i do
have a theory that she could be the
power broker but we'll save that for
later in the video
sharon has been living in madrapore
since the events of civil war has
basically made her persona non-grata
she offers the boys a place to crash in
her swanky apartment in hightown
where it looks like she's made a living
selling famous artwork like monet's 1875
piece
woman with a parasol sharon and the team
catch up she's a bit bitter how falcon
never got in touch with her and how he
gave up the shield but
falcon needs her help saying that he can
get her name cleared in exchange for
help getting nagel if they could get
bucky's name cleared why not hers
during the party we see more famous
paintings like van gogh's self-portrait
and modigliani's portrait of a young
woman from 1918
but the real art here is zemo's dancing
sharon has tracked down the location of
nagel to a secret shipping lab by the
port while she holds guard the boys
interrogate nagel who was picked up by
the cia to continue testing his work he
took blood from isaiah bradley who we
met last
episode and was able to isolate the
compounds to create a super soldier
serum now he was working for the cia and
who else do we know that's working with
them
the new cap which fits into a theory
that the new cap will eventually take
one of these serums it was after
nagel returned from the blip that he was
approached by the power broker to
continue his work where he managed to
create
20 vials of the stuff which carly
morgenthau eventually stole
nagel even refers to abraham erskine the
creator of the original super soldier
serum which helped transform steve
rogers into captain america
but before we can get any more info from
nagel he's shot by zemo with a gun he
found under one of the lab desks and the
place is soon overrun by
bounty hunters there is a fun action
scene where one hunter is pretty much
speared to death by a pipe and zemo
comes to save the day
now donning his purple mask and is able
to steal a pretty nice car from a
shipping container so they can make
their escape now sharon says she has to
leave them after all she can't leave
madrapore for fear of getting caught
and this is where things just aren't
adding up with her and i wouldn't be
surprised if she
were the power broker let's look at what
we know she just happens to be at the
bar when bucky and falcon arrive she
kills selby
she's the one to save them i also think
she set up that bounty
she also magically knows where dr nagle
is she's super rich and tells the boys
she has to meet with quote
clients during her extravagant party and
how did all these bounty hunters know
exactly where the team was gonna be
she tells her bodyguard after this event
that they have a big
problem on their hands what could that
mean the show has also made an effort
not to show the power brokers face
meaning the power broker will likely be
a big reveal we also know the power
broker wants carly as seen at the end of
episode 2 when the broker's henchmen try
to catch her falcon and bucky are also
looking for her too so it would make
sense she's piggybacking with them
not to mention she has some pent-up
resentment for bucky and falcon let's
not forget that sharon doesn't join the
boys when they visit nagel who obviously
would have outed her that
is if he ever saw her in the first place
back in the car falcon tells bucky
you're not gonna move your seat up are
you which is a callback to civil war
can you move your ceno no meanwhile in
lithuania dovich asks carly if she's
taken the time to mourn
in the promo material we do see her
attending a funeral
so this could be next episode harley
wants to take the serum and give it to
the kids in those camps to give them a
chance
carly also happens to know that nagel
was killed in madrapore
and now that he's gone the power broker
will need carly as she's the only one
who has the serum back in berlin camp
and lamar learned that falcon and bucky
may have been involved in
zemo's escape but they have no evidence
wait till those videos come out
on the private jet zemos made snacks
bucky and falcon talk about how many
people had to be
steamrolled in order to make cap's
shield what was the cost
of making captain america it's a
metaphor for america itself
a country seen as a beacon of liberty
and justice
but its history is filled with events
like slavery the boys arrive in latvia
where we learn that the former sokovia
has been
cannibalized by its neighbors a macabre
way of saying its
neighbors took over its land zemo and
falcon are on their way to a memorial
we've seen this memorial in some of the
promo footage yet we don't have an
answer yet as to why these two images
look
different if you want to hear my
theories on that check out my episode 2
breakdown bucky says he's going to go
for a walk it's obvious he's sent
something or perhaps
even has prior knowledge of this meeting
he follows these commodore beats
advanced wakandan technology made from
vibranium we've seen used in black
panther
these beads can serve multiple functions
such as wound stabilization and
communication the word kimoyo comes from
bantu meaning
of the spirit bucky follows these beads
like a trail of breadcrumbs where the
episode ends on the arrival of eo the
second in command
of the dora melange we can even see she
has those beads around her wrist it's
clear bucky and ayo would know each
other
after all bucky spent years in wakanda
she is looking for zemo and no wonder
zemo was responsible for killing king
t'chaka
so bucky's in an awkward position here
he needs zemo's help but
how far is he willing to go to fend off
ayo and the wakandans
the answers for that we'll just have to
wait till next week
thanks for watching everyone if you
liked this video be sure to like
subscribe and share
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
i